fans eagerly awaiting the december 17th
release of netflix's the witcher season
2 can now get their monsters mages and
magic fix in the form of director quang
ilhan's animated spin-off film the
witcher nightmare of the wolf here's
everything you need to know about the
prequel's poignant ending
the prequel focuses on the backstory of
vessemir geralt of rivia's mentor and
father figure who's set to be played by
kim bodnia in the live-action series
second season this prequel chronicles
the events that led him to become a
witcher as well as the experiences that
forced him to rethink his beliefs
priorities and values
since those values were passed on to
geralt the film serves to bridge the gap
between the geralt of season 1 and the
geralt created over the course of the
series source material by andrei
sapkovsky although the witcher nightmare
of the wolf is not strictly speaking a
depiction of anything from the novels
the film's writer beau dimeo was intent
on creating something that worked within
the canon and franchise
in an interview with cbr dimeo discussed
the challenge of delving into storylines
the books doesn't necessarily
investigate while simultaneously staying
true to their character's narrative he
explained i started thinking about who
was vesimir at the start of his career
before the horrible things that happened
with the witchers in the canon in
exploring these untapped arcs and
focusing on what he called that
unanswerable mystery in the witcher
nightmare of the wolf touches on a
number of themes integral to sapkovsky's
original works and helped give fans a
deeper understanding of the dynamics of
both the continent and the various
factions within it it's difficult not to
read sapkowski's original saga as a
commentary on the tumultuous and
war-torn history of his home country of
poland nightmare of the wolf foregrounds
themes such as class and racial divide
societal constructs and the symbolic
relationship between fear and violence
ignorance and hate
when we first meet vesemir he's a young
viral witcher equivalent of a bro dude
focused mainly on collecting coin and
living it up when he can but the hunky
hexer's laissez-faire attitude belies a
deep-seated desire to rise above the
impoverished social status of his youth
flashbacks to vesimir's childhood reveal
that he was born into servitude and
longed for nothing more than to free
himself and his childhood love ilyana
from the shackles of their station at
the beginning of his narrative we're
shown a vesimir who still harbors hatred
for the nobility he's so envious but by
the end of nightmare of the wolf he's
determined to live for something more
meaningful than glory coin and status
aliana faces her own fair share of
classism when she grows into adulthood
even as she rises through the ranks of
society in vesimir's absence eliana
marries the son of the noble family that
claims her and upon his death inherits
his title advisor to the king it soon
becomes clear however that even as lady
zerps she has difficulty commanding the
respect her position should by right
demand though her late husband clearly
saw her as an equal the nobility and
their ilk never do in the end it's
eliana's untimely death that finally
forces vesimir to confront the
misguidedness of his priorities
vesimir's priorities of coin and glory
are shared and reinforced by his own
mentor deglin when vestemir tells the
frightened abandoned orphans at
caramoran that they'll gain strength
purpose and respect as the next
generation of witchers he's merely
parroting what he was told by deaglin as
a child the need for this kind of
purpose in life is exactly what drives
deglin to engage in the mutagenic
alchemy for which the witchers are
ultimately condemned and nearly wiped
out he tells vesimir monsters were going
extinct i had to protect our way of life
deaglin feels forced to create new
monsters because it's only mankind's
reliance on the witchers for protection
from the world's scarier beasts that
keeps them from turning on and hunting
down witchers now they finally have
turned on the witchers with a little
push from the witcher hating mage tetra
gilchrist though ulyana doesn't agree
with deglan's approach she does tell
vesimir that war was inevitable as she
puts it killing is easier than
tolerating on the surface tetra is the
most outspoken racist in nightmare of
the wolf tetra even goes so far as to
publish propaganda pamphlets denouncing
witchers whom she views as corrupt
mutations in contrast to her pure mage
lineage as rogues without virtue it's
not easy being a witcher
trust me
i'd know in the end we learned there's
more to tetra's hateful conviction than
meets the eye her fervent hatred of
witchers stems from her past experience
with a single witcher an extremist who
tricked a priest into believing that
tetra's mother was possessing him in the
same way that vesamir's experience with
one particular nobleman as a child
colored his understanding of the world
from there on out tetra's traumatic
experience with a radical rogue witcher
in turn radicalized her might have
slightly underestimated you
slightly
the witcher nightmare of the wolf
highlights the interconnected cyclical
nature of many of society's worst
impulses ignorance begets fear fear
begets hate hate begets violence and so
on in the end only ilyana seems capable
of breaking the cycle when she asks
vesimir to forgive the tragically
mutated kitsu for her murder nightmare
of the wolf repeatedly explores the idea
of illusion both magical and
metaphorical for most of his life
vesimir is motivated by the illusion of
wealth and status though as a witcher he
obtains both it's a superficial victory
and one that doesn't ultimately bring
him happiness moreover in the end it's a
literal illusion that causes him to kill
the only woman he ever loved although
it's vesemir who falls victim to the
most devastating illusion of all it's
tetra who delivers the film's message to
viewers she tells vesemir of the mages
practice of casting illusions around
undesirable foods making them taste
better before going on to explain that
the telltale sign of an illusion is its
bitter aftertaste
there's more than a little irony
embedded in the reaction that some fans
had to the witcher season one creator's
decision not to use race or even gender
as a basis for casting canonical
characters when show runner lauren
hissrick was criticized for altering the
arguably only ever implied races of
various characters she had this to say
on twitter the witcher is really
interesting when it comes to depicting
racism because it's about species not
skin color what makes characters other
is the shape of their ears height etc in
the books no one pays attention to skin
color in the series no one does either
period it's an instance of life
imitating art supposed die-hard fans of
sapovsky's work directly embodied and
made incarnate one of the saga's main
allegories if the witcher season 1
introduced audiences to the dynamics of
the story's key players then the witcher
nightmare of the wolf introduced them to
a deeper understanding of the dynamics
of the continent and its history and in
doing so open the door for the witcher
season 2 to answer some of the
philosophical questions it poses
i need to understand some things
although we don't discover which of the
camera and orphans is the young white
wolf until the last scene the impact the
events of the story have on his future
mentor give audiences a more thorough
understanding of the upbringing that
created the hero at the heart of the
netflix series but they hate us
they'll always be another monster
geralt
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the witcher universe are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you